You got to play more lens.
>> We're not playing enough for removal.
Counter spells are good.
>> You need to play more protection spells.
>> Try these mana rocks. So, people have
been calling me a fraud for suggesting
cards all day, every day, but never
talking about what to cut. True, fair
criticism. Part of the reason, though,
is that I also suck at cutting cards.
Not my fault, though. Cards nowadays are
just so good. Look at this. And this
crap. These are what I used to play. And
these are really easy to cut. Not at the
time, but in hindsight, these are some
terrible cards. But nowadays, every
spoiler season is like, that's a stable.
That's a stable. Oo, just 20 more
stables from this one set. Wow. We And
ratio is really freaking difficult to
figure out in this format. There are
just way too many variables for the
collection of any meaningful data. So,
it's more like, uh, I died to a blight
steel last game, so I guess I'm adding
one more exile removal. Oh, that reminds
me. My commander ate a path to exile
last game that got me a land. Guess I'm
cutting a land. Yeah, perfect logic.
Time for a lunch break. It's like
navigating a dark cave is all vibes and
nothing else. And you know what they
say, where there is shade, there is
shady business. These fraudulent pieces
of cardboard, they rely more on vibes
than substance. I mean, you can farm
reputation in some other format for a
season and feed off of it for years in
commander. Some of my play groups still
makes barely audible noises at the sight
of a Jace the mine sculptor. And today
we are here to expose them. Hello, this
is Jyn with Next Level Commander and
today we are picking out some of the
biggest frauds in your commander decks
so we can make room for the shiny new
universes beyond stuff. Okay, some of
these may range from little to very
debatable, but we have a fraud here
somewhere. It's either the cards or it's
me, so you're definitely not leaving
empty-handed today. We'll start with
crime on a smaller scale and build up to
the farreaching schemes. The top pick
today has snuck its way into over 2
million decks. But we'll start with a
classic. Number 10, Wrath of God in
nearly 170,000 decks. While the black
counterpart, Damination is a little more
excusable due to black's relative lack
of quality board wipes. White has no
excuse. Yes, I get it. They never made a
strict upgrade over this card because
they still care about formats like
standard. But in commander, we usually
have time. But I mean, if you're
consistently getting pressured on turn
four, by all means, play it. Actually,
you probably need more ramp if that's
the case. But, but generally speaking,
for just a little extra mana, you get so
much more value and versatility. Let's
start with Fumigate. This isn't even the
best one. But for five mana, you're not
only undoing their creatures, but a
decent chunk of the damage they've dealt
to you. Basically, a time warp if you
squint hard enough. Or we can get the
versatility of blowing up artifacts and
enchantments depending on your mood
swing. Starfall Invocation is also
really really pushed. I mean, even
Necroantic Selection is a pretty solid
card. And lastly, route. I talk about
this card every chance I get. It's not
even a tenth as popular as Raph, but
trust me, all it takes is wiping once at
instant speed and you are not going
back. And just one more mana, we are in
the territory of game changers. So ask
yourself, do you play in a troll meta?
No, not your friends. I mean the
creatures. If not, do you need a wipe on
turn four? Also, no. Well,
congratulations. You are due for an
upgrade. Next up, Harmonize. 250,000
decks. It's like having Skype credit
subscriptions in 2025. Nobody
consciously decides to play harmonize
anymore. You probably just forgot to opt
out. And the card is never terrible, so
you don't think about it. Now, if your
deck is in green, you're probably
creature based. And if it isn't, you
probably have other colors with better
draw spells. So for these creature
decks, whether you're going tall or
wide, we have far more explosive and
mana efficient draw options than
Harmonites. Again, it's not terrible,
but it better not be blocking the way
for something like Live Stream's
Blessing. That card is so good. Okay, we
started off kind of mild, but we are
just warming up. The next card is seeing
in 350,000 decks, and this number will
probably double if budget wasn't an
issue. Force of Will. Yes, the legacy
and CEDH staple living in off of its
reputation from completely different
formats than casual commander. Does your
deck or commander generate so much card
advantage that you would rather lose a
card than to spend one or two extra
mana? Sure, in clutch moments it may be
worth it and that's why it's getting
CEDH because every moment in CDH is
clutch and you don't get as many moments
because the game ends on turn five. But
for them bracket two and bracket three
games, those moments will be less
clutched and more spread out throughout
a longer game. Oftentimes you'll be
short on cards rather than mana and you
look into maybe just hard casting it.
Holy googly moogly. It's five mana.
Yeah, this is why I think force of
negation is actually better overall. Not
many creatures are worth countering
anyways. So yeah, force of will leeching
off of its reputation from legacy and
cedh draining people's wallets. Cut it
and trade it for some flesh lens or
something. Number seven, we have another
counter spell, but even more popular and
even worse, red elemental blast and pyro
blast, which is basically the same
thing. This felonious duel is taking up
over 400,000 card slots. People have
this obsession with playing these
suboptimal color pipe breaks. I mean,
sure, Pongify back in the days because
it's also really freaking mana
efficient, but not every deck has to
have a counter spell, especially when
it's not good. People are rating Pyro
Blast based on the few times it gets the
expropriate or omniscience hype. I know,
but what about the other 20 times when
it's a dead card in your hand or when
you counter something barely relevant?
It's just like when people play Ty. If
living for those hype moments is why you
play Magic, sure, go for it. But when it
comes to winning or being more
consistent, you're much better off
taking advantage of what your colors are
good at rather than trying to patch
their weaknesses. Another problem with
these counter spells is it really messes
with your threat assessment. Take the
manetate example again. Players would
use that card whenever someone taps out
because that's like their only window.
Gotcha. Haha. Without really thinking
about if the card countered will
actually hurt you and if it's worth
making an enemy over it. Pyro blast has
a similar dynamic to a lesser extent.
How often are you countering a card
because it happens to be blue rather
than it actually being any threat to
you? Say you see this on the stack,
Arctavia. It's big. It's blue. It seems
like the perfect target for Pyro Blast.
But then if someone else is ahead at the
table, what's the chance of this
actually coming at you? Just countering
this, you probably made an enemy for
nothing and helped an opponent more than
yourself. Number six, we have a classic
Farrexian arena found in over 500,000
decks, many of which with blue. But I
can't be making fun of you. I was fooled
for years until the direct upgrades
finally hammered it home for me. This is
one of the best examples of how far
momentum can carry a card's reputation.
It was a staple in the early days of
commander, but in the year of 2025, it
just it doesn't do enough. If you were
lucky enough to drop it on turn three,
sure it's decent, but even then it will
take till turn six to be roughly equal
to a read the bones. And imagine in the
midame top decking this instead of say
insatiable avarice or siphon mind. Yeah,
siphon mind is still a sweet card, but
farian arena on the other hand is not.
Number five, feed the swarm. Now, I have
an entire video about why sorcery speed
removals are bad, so we won't be talking
about that as much. But most people are
playing this card because it patches
your color's weakness, but like we
rented about earlier, is patching
weakness what we should be doing? I
mean, you can't patch everything. Sure,
now we have a single card that can deal
with risic studies and smothering
tights, but what about say sorceries?
You're still going to lose to
expropriates and primal surges and
interactions. No. Now, before you say
black can't deal with sorceries. Yes, it
can. Warping will. But you don't play
this because it's just not a very good
card. The same logic can and should be
applied to feed the swarm. If you're in
mono black, maybe still probably not.
But if you're in any other color in
addition to black, please cut this card.
All right, number four, chromatic
lantern. Not the hottest take here. This
one is quite commonly accepted as being
overrated at this point, but still over
600,000 decks. I mean, okay, in
fivecolor decks maybe, but even five
color nowadays has excellent budget
fixing. They keep printing reasonably
costed dual lens. Your fixing should be
fine as long as you play a bit of rep.
But three color decks, this is where you
are scamming yourself. Do you also have
an oil change subscription for your
Tesla? Let's just say if you're having
trouble fixing in a threecolor deck,
your problem goes far beyond what a
little lantern can solve. Get that land
base fixed up. I mean, look at the
filter lands. These used to be 10 $15
and now bulk and they're sweet. These
used to be a few dollars as well. build
a solid mana base instead of wishing to
top decks some mana rock to fix your
issues. And by extension, there's also
Lelayan of the Guild Pact. Typical
example of a card that sounds sweet but
doesn't actually do anything. Unless
you're doing the combos, I guess. Okay,
we are reaching the truly controversial
ones. This is probably going to be
considered a rage bait by many, but
you've made it this far. I don't think
further baiting is needed. Anyways,
thank you for sticking with me, but our
lovely little relationship might be
ending here.
over 630,000 decks. Tossic deluge, which
I'm sure will soon be an apt description
of my poor comment section. I mean, this
card is rated number one by a lot of
lists. It definitely looks sweet at
three mana, which is near unprecedented
for a board wipe, and it's flexible in
that you can keep larger creatures
around if you happen to control them.
But then, why do you need to wipe if you
have the best board? Now, imagine the
reverse scenario when your opponents
have the biggest board. Yeah, it's
almost like that's when you want to
wipe, right? Let's say Jimmy has a 1313.
Do you play 13 life to kill it or do you
leave it and get smacked? Doesn't seem
too good either way. Even six for seven
life, I totally pay an extra mana to
gain six life in commander, especially
if it doesn't cost me a card. So unless
again we are constantly getting
pressured on turn three, just play
damnation or the new one. Yeah,
Blasphemous Edict. This is the one that
should be a staple. One reason I believe
Duch is popular is again because of
CEDH. Well, if it's good enough for a
CEDH, it must be. Nope. That's a pretty
common misconception actually like we
talked about earlier. Yeah, CDH is
effectively a different format with far
more action in the first few turns of
the game. In the games usually earned
one or lost by grinding down life
totals. In that scenario, toxic halu is
perfect. In the slower metag games
though, paying more mana for something
like Kindred's dominance or blood money
can get you so much more value. In a
similar vein is our number two today, a
fraudulent little critter in Birds of
Paradise. Approaching 900,000 victims.
Well, you'd think in a format where no
one plays lightning bolt bird would be
unbeatable, right? Wrong. The common
theme of these CDH or 60 card Allstars
is that they trade long-term value for
short-term explosivity. But in slower
and grindier formats like the one we
play, this is justifiable in far fewer
decks. Is your commander three mana?
Does it escalate and snowball if you
drop it on turn two? If so, maybe. But
the graph looks kind of like this.
Explosiveness versus longevity. The
sweet spot for most casual commander
decks is somewhere between repentant
growth and cultivate cards like birds
and dark ritual are for the most extreme
cases. And finally, congratulations for
making it this far. We have our heavy
hitter for today. Fleam Goblin's
creation.
Just kidding. It's relicate tower. Yeah,
this is such an easy card to put into
every deck because it's a land. But
nowadays, even lens requires brings. And
I'm not talking about fixing, but the
growing collection of utility lands that
are synergizing beautifully with our
commanders and our decks. But instead,
you play relic tower. People don't like
discarding just like many hate being
mil, but it's silly. How often does your
deck really needs that eighth card? Do
you really need two threats, two counter
spells, three removals, and two lands
held your hand? If you're discarding
down to hand size in the Midame or
beyond, you're probably already doing
well. So, this is just win more. And
it's easy to remember the times when we
draw 14 cards and get to keep them all,
but gloss over when we get color screwed
or the opportunity cost of other utility
lands. It's stopping you from casting
your spells and imagine how much
trickier your mulligan would be if you
open with this in a three-color deck.
So, ditch the tower and try some of
these new utility lands. They even make
colored mana. So, here's the list.
Again, every one of these are playable
in specific decks and scenarios, but the
number suggests that they are being
played in way more than that. So, take
another look at these cards and see if
you can find something better. And it's
not just about these 10 individual
cards. It's more about these categories
of cards that can mislead people into
overrating them and even treating them
as default inclusions. Can you think of
any cards like that? Or is there
anything on this list that you're still
going to firmly hold on to? Let me know
in the comments. This is Jyn with Next
Level Commander. Subscribe if you like
this kind of content and I will see you
in the next